fiesta nacional para celebrar el regreso
del talibán en afganistán los
fundamentalistas islámicos conmemoran
este lunes el primer aniversario de la
toma de kabul la capital que se dio tras
la apertura de retirada de las tropas de
occidente liderada por eeuu el 15 de
agosto de 2021
con la ayuda de dios todo es posible no
éramos conscientes pero hemos llegado
aquí con la ayuda de dios nunca
olvidaremos en nuestra vida la felicidad
de ese día en el que el señor nos dio
tal victoria así que estamos muy
contentos gracias a dios más abalario
[Música]
estamos muy contentos de haber derrotado
a eeuu todos los compañeros están muy
contentos mi mensaje a las personas que
huyeron al extranjero que son médicos e
ingenieros o que trabajaban para el
gobierno anterior es que vuelvan a su
país los brazos del emirato islámico
están abiertos para ellos los
necesitamos
pese a las celebraciones en las calles
para muchos en el país es del lunes
están lejos de ser festivo en el último
año afganistán se ha visto sumido en una
galopante crisis alimentaria más de la
mitad de los 38 millones de afganos vive
bajo el umbral de la pobreza el sector
bancario está hundido y el 60% de la
ayuda humanitaria extranjera no ha
llegado además enfermedades como el
cólera han rebrotado en el sur del país
en esta degradación a todas las escalas
las mujeres han sido asimismo las
grandes perjudicadas con un borrado casi
total de sus derechos
y realmente durante este año se han
producido cambios negativos en la vida
de todos los afganos especialmente para
las mujeres y yo soy una de ellas me han
impedido trabajar y todo lo demás la
mayoría de días me siento triste y
desanimada eso se absoluta químico no
eso se va a llevar en des neta a pesar
de sus promesas iniciales los talibanes
volvieron a implantar la interpretación
más estricta del islam que ya
caracterizó la primera llegada al poder
entre 1996 y 2001